Good morning.
Today's lecture is entitled the Prince and the Palace human made divine on the
Palatine hill and I want to begin essentially where we left off and that is with
the emperor Vespasian,
the founder of the Flavian dynasty and the political shrewdness that Vespasian
demonstrated when he made the decisions that he did when he made the decision,
especially to use architecture to further his political agenda.
And you'll recall that the way in which he did that was that he,
and I'm just going to show you the site plan once again on the eschalon and
Palatine hills,
the site plan that shows us how he did this,
how he did this was he recognized that he didn't want to associate himself with
neuro,
but it was to his advantage to soap,
to associate himself instead with the emperor Claudius.
And he did that by finishing the platform and indeed the temple itself that we
looked at at that time where we looked at last time and that is the temple of
the divine Claudius,
the Claudine them that had been begun by Agra [inaudible],
the younger he completed that as a nod to Claudius.
And again,
a very smart political move on his part.
He also is,
you'll recall raised the Dome is area of neuro to the ground,
covered up what was left of it otherwise,
and then he filled in the artificial lake.
I had to use the property that the artificial lake was on to build the coliseum,
which itself was a shrewd gift to the Roman people to gain their favor.
Uh,
and he did succeed in that regard.
Equally important,
perhaps even more important is the decision that Vespasian made in the year 79 a
d and that decision.
And we see a portrait once again a Vespasian on the right hand side of the
screen.
Now in Copenhagen,
the decision he made in [inaudible] 79 was to a point,
his elder son Titus as coal region.
And we see a portrait of Titus on the lefthand side of the screen and military
costume.
Uh,
we see him.
It's a portrait that was found in Herculaneum,
uh,
so that we know it needs to date prior to 79.
Uh,
so very likely some time in the 70s,
that particular statue was put up.
Now,
the reason it was smart politically to a point,
Titus as his co region was at Titus was extremely capable.
He was also extremely popular in Rome with the people with the Senate.
And,
uh,
what it did was to ensure the succession to ensure the succession.
And so when Vespasian died of natural causes in 79,
a d Titus was to take over and indeed,
indeed he did.
And he took over without any contest whatsoever,
which was,
it was a great accomplishment.
Titus,
however,
I,
oh,
and Titus by the way,
was young when he became emperor.
He was in his early thirties,
about 32 full of energy,
uh,
and he needed it for what lay ahead because he was unlucky.
Uh,
and his,
his,
uh,
his reign was affected by three major events of the first of which,
you know,
intimately already.
And that is the eruption of Vesuvius in 79 and Titus is reign was 79 to 81.
So in 79,
a d a d a Vesuvius erupts and Titus has to deal with the consequences of that
covered over,
as you well know,
almost all of campaign.
Yet in the year 80,
uh,
he suffered a Rome suffered a very serious plague,
which Titus also had to deal with.
You have to marshal all of his energy and all his ingenuity to deal with a very
serious plague in row.
It's very serious plague in Rome.
And that plague was,
was followed by a fire,
also an exceedingly serious fire.
Uh,
so Titus had his hands Bolen perhaps it's not surprising given all the stress of
those years that he too died of natural causes in 81 at a very young age.
But despite what he went through during [inaudible] 79 to 81 Titus Titus,
his claim to fame was something that happened much earlier.
And I've mentioned it before and that is something that happened already in the
year.
[inaudible] 70,
and it was in the year [inaudible] 70 that Vespasian sent his elder son to
Jerusalem to Judea to get involved in a major military war.
Uh,
and it was Titus as you'll recall,
who was victorious in the Jewish wars.
And that took place in 78 [inaudible] 78 d and it was extremely important,
not only in itself from Rome standpoint,
uh,
but also because it provided legitimacy to the Flavian dynasty.
I mentioned that the,
uh,
that when a Roman dynasty came to power in a civil war,
which was the case both for Augustus after the civil war 40,
uh,
the civil war,
that was,
that Rome was plunged into after Caesar's death.
Uh,
and was a case again for Vespasian after the chaos of the year 68 69,
they needed a foreign victory to gain legitimacy.
So for the Flavian Dynasty,
the war,
uh,
over Jerusalem was,
gave them that legitimacy and was therefore extremely important in terms of the
art and ideology of the Flavian Dynasty.
I want to turn to an arch that was put up in honor of that very victory over
Jerusalem.
Uh,
sometime after Aidy d one,
it was the so called arch of Titus,
the most,
one of the most famous Roman monuments of all,
uh,
and it was put up,
although it bears Titus,
his name,
it was put up not by him but by his brother mission.
His younger brother Domitian who succeeded him after Titus is death,
which is why we date it to some time after a d 81,
I want to show you first it's location because that itself is significant.
We are looking at the Google Earth view of the Roman forum.
You see the Roman forum here,
you see the Colosseum up at the top center.
Uh,
you see the Capitoline hill or Compa Doleo here,
the victor of Manual Monument Tier pointed these out many times before the via
de Fori am periodically of the selenium,
the imperial fora to the left.
Again,
the Roman forum here and the Palatine Hill,
which we're going to be concentrating on today.
But you'll remember that Nero's hope was to link the Palatine Hill with the
Escalade inhale,
which is why right up to the left of the coliseum.
And to do that via a spur hill,
a spur hell that's located right here,
a bit above my finger.
Uh,
they spur hill called the Veolia B e l I a,
uh,
that was to link the two.
And you'll remember Nero's plans for his dome is transitory.
This palace that was to serve as a point of transit between those two hills.
And you'll recall also,
uh,
the remains of some of the rooms from the domus transitory.
So this was again,
land that had been,
that had been built up by Nero.
So it's not surprising to see the flavor ones once again,
a Titus following suit and then his younger brother demission following suit to
use land that had earlier been used by Nero for new Flavian monuments.
In this case,
an arch put up to the victory that Titus celebrated over Jerusalem.
And if you look very carefully,
again,
just a bit,
a few inches above where my finger is,
you will see,
uh,
the arch of Titus,
standing on that spur hill.
I'm the Veolia between the pallet time and the Escalade hills,
the arch of Titus again,
which dates to after [inaudible] 81 was placed right next to the sacred way or
the via Socra.
It doesn't span the street,
but it's placed right next to it,
adjacent to it,
and I think you can see that very well in these two views here,
which also showed that a quite a bit of ancient road actually survives or a
piece of ancient Rome wrote actually survives in the Roman forum.
It's on the slope that you see here and you can see the way in which it goes
right by the arch of Titus that you'd see two,
it's right.
This is a view up the hill up the sacred way toward the Veolia and here down
from the arch of Titus down into the rest of the forum.
And again,
you can see the polygonal masonry of the ancient road still preserved the
ancient way.
This the via sock Rowe was the road that the triumphant general took when he
returned to Rome after a great military victories.
So this is exactly the road that Titus himself would have taken when he came
back from,
from Judea,
uh,
and,
and walked in triumph or road and triumph in his chariot along the sacred way
and up to the capital line hill because the triumphant general,
uh,
who was,
garbed in with the attributes of Jupiter in this procession made his way up to
the Capitoline hill would,
would get off his chariot up there,
right at the altar in front of the Temple of Jupiter Omc and make a sacrifice to
Jupiter.
So you have to imagine a Titus doing this along with Vespasian cause you'll
remember I mentioned to you that they celebrated a joint triumph that Titus was
willing to share his triumph with his father.
Vespasian.
Uh,
so they both would have come in,
in triumph into Rome after this great victory.
Once again,
you can see the arch in the view on the right,
another view of the our cheer,
which shows it on the Veolia.
And here you can get a very good sense of the way in which that spur hill unites
the Palatine and the SQL line as well as the proximity of the arch of Titus to
the coliseum.
We are seeing that the Flavian is or building up a certain area of Rome,
uh,
with their monuments.
And this is no exception.
The view that we see here from the forum of the one side of the arch of Titus
shows a modern inscription,
but we'll see that there is an ancient inscription on the other side and we're
also going to see that although the arch looks very well preserved,
it was actually quite heavily restored by an architect by the name of a Giussep
Bay Bala Da.
And that happened in the 19th century.
That ball la Da da La d I e r Giuseppe Viola da restored the arch of Titus.
And the part of the,
the arch that is ancient is essentially the central section right here,
the,
the uh,
mostly on the other side,
actually on this side,
just the spandrels and the inner panels here.
And on the other side we'll see.
Well,
I'll show you when we get to the other side.
So this side,
important to know that the inscription is a modern one.
Here's the other side of the arch where you can see again,
the central section is ancient with the spandrels.
These triangular areas here.
Uh,
the columns on this side are ancient.
The keystone is ancient.
The frees up above,
uh,
the keystone is ancient,
the inscription is ancient on this side,
but all the rest was restored by Viola Da.
Uh,
as I said in the 19th century and Viola da did something very interesting and
archeologically very,
very forward thinking in that since the center of the arch was made out of Greek
marble pentelic marble,
C pentelic marble from Mt.
Penn Telecon in Greece,
which in itself is interesting because we saw that the Flavian Ian's,
we're using imported marbles in their buildings.
I've mentioned that already before.
So we see a continuation of that trend here,
use of pentelic marble for the arch.
Uh,
but when Viola da did the restorations,
he or the reconstruction,
he used travertine,
uh,
for the modern parts of the arch.
So that when you probably isn't so evident to you from this view,
but when you stand in front of the art,
you can see the difference in the materials.
And he wanted to point out to the spectator that there was a difference between
the ancient part of the monument and the modern part of the monument as restored
by him.
This view on the left,
there are quite a number of,
uh,
preserved paintings and engravings that show the arch before the Valar da
reconstruction.
And you see one of those over there.
And you can see we're looking at the fame side of the arch here as we are here.
So once again,
you can see the ancient survived of the ancient arch,
the central part,
the two columns on basis,
uh,
the keystone,
the,
the spandrels,
uh,
freeze,
and then the,
and then the inscription.
What does that say?
Great.
Okay,
fine.
We'll accept that.
Uh,
so,
and we see that here and this is another one of those Roman monuments that was
essentially preserve because of reuse over time,
or at least the part of it that it still exists.
And this was turned into as so many other monuments was turned into a fortress
at one point,
a fortress that was owned by the front Japonais family in Italy.
So that's the ancient part,
the rest restored by Viola Da.
And you have to also reconstruct and your mind's eye,
uh,
that this arch would have served as a kind of statue base for a representation
or for a sculptural group,
uh,
in bronze that would have represented Titus and perhaps this beige and also
together seated did in a chariot being led by four horses.
Uh,
uh,
great.
Quadric a group that was customarily placed on the top of such arches.
Below that,
the inscription plaque below that is upper,
already described a freeze.
I'm going to show you that freeze in a moment.
Then the spandrels and then in the center here,
two great panels,
one on either figural panels,
one on either side of the arch.
You see the inscription here,
it's interesting because it tells us that it was the senate and people of Rome,
the Spq are the Senate and people of Rome who put this up to the divine.
Titus DOL,
Tito,
as you can see here.
And the divine Titus who was the son is an f for affiliates right over here.
Uh,
the son of the divine Vespasian.
So the divinity of both of these men,
both of whom were made gods at their death is alluded to here.
So the Senate and people of Rome put this up to the divine.
Titus,
the son of the divine Vespasian.
And if you can see all of these little holes that are located in some of the
letters or the reason for though those is that those were were bronze letters
were actually attached a,
so these letters were inscribed and then bronze letters were attached to them.
Uh,
so that the inscription would gleam in the science,
Sean.
And so that you could see it from a considerable distance.
Down below the inscription plaque,
we see the freeze,
which purports to represent this great procession of parade that took place when
best buy,
when Titus returned from Jerusalem,
uh,
and had his triumphal procession along the sacred way and add up to the Capitol
on Hill and the Temple of Jupiter.
Uh,
and you can see that the artist has,
uh,
has made the figures fairly small,
but at the same time has,
has made each one distinct from the other so that this is more readable from the
ground.
And then below that declaration of the keystone and then in either a spandrel or
triangular area at either side of the keystones,
we see victories flying Vic flying female figures of victory that are of course
making reference in a general way,
uh,
to this great victory that that's the tightest had over Jerusalem.
Important from the architectural standpoint are the columns and especially the
capitals.
I show you a detail of one of the preserved there too again,
but one of the two preserved capitols from this side of the arch,
the arch that the side that faces the Coliseum and you see it here and it's a
distinctive capital that we have not seen before.
Uh,
it's a capital that actually combines the Corinthian and the ionic because you
can see the Corinthian,
a canvas leaves growing up here,
uh,
flowers as we see in the,
in the usual Corinthian order.
And then,
uh,
prominent volumes of the ionic order up above.
We refer to this as the composite capitol,
the composite capitol combining Corinthian and ionic.
We see it quite infrequently in Roman architecture,
but we do see it on occasion.
Uh,
so it's good for you to know about in the center of the bay,
I mentioned that there were two break figural panels and these figural panels
make reference to,
uh,
to Titus is victory over Jerusalem to this important event from the point of
view of the Flavian that gave their dynasty legitimacy.
And we see one of those here.
We actually see an image of Titus in his chariot and he's riding alone without
his father.
Uh,
he's riding alone in his chariot,
uh,
with the exception of a female figure who accompanies him.
Uh,
and you can see that female figure is winging it and she is a personification of
victory.
So she has heralding the victory that he has had in Jerusalem.
And in fact,
she holds a Laurel wreath above his head,
crowning him.
Because of that victory,
the chariot is led by four horses who are whizzing by as you can see here,
uh,
and they are led at the front by a woman in a helmet and military costume who
might well be Roma,
the personification of Rome herself.
And what is she doing?
She's welcoming Titus back to Rome after his great victory over Jerusalem over
here.
Two other figures,
a two other male figures,
both headless today,
but one of them,
uh,
in a toga and the other figure with a bare chest and a mantle rapped over the
lower part of his body.
Because we have the same figures in other reliefs.
We know despite the fact that they are headless,
that these are personifications of the Senate,
the dressed person,
the person in Toga is the Senate,
the gayness,
GE Nius like genius,
the gain new Sonatas or the spirit of the Senate.
And this,
the gain use papillae Romani which was the,
the representative of the Roman people.
So keep in mind,
again,
it was the senate and people of Rome that put up a,
the arch to Titus at the son of the divine Vespasian and we see them selves rep
or their personifications represented in this scene.
More interesting from our standpoint.
Visa v Architecture is the other scene on the other side of the Central Bay,
uh,
where we see the Roman soldiers or a group of Roman soldiers bringing back
spoils or booty trophies from Jerusalem,
things that they have stolen from the temple in Jerusalem.
And you can see the famous seven branch candle labrum that they are carrying
here.
The weight is so great that it is,
that they're,
they're,
uh,
shoulders bend under that weight.
Uh,
and we also see them with a table over here that has a number of sacrificial
implements and so on that were taken also from the temple in Jerusalem.
So they carry these along in this parade for the people to see for those
enrollment to see,
to get a real palpable sense of what it meant to have this victory and of the
spoils that are being brought back.
And you can see that this is represented very illusionistic Lee.
And you can see that they seem to be a walking through an art that is also
represented here.
A very interesting,
uh,
seen indeed.
And you'll recall,
uh,
what,
what they did with those spoils.
They took those spoils and they put them in the temple and pockets that we
talked about last time or the forum pockets that we talked about last time that
served essentially as a kind of museum,
uh,
where the people of Rome could see these images.
So,
once again,
the Flavian is always showing and affinity for and an interest in,
uh,
the people of the city,
that they were trying of course to court favor from.
So we're seeing demission,
uh,
who again was the commissioner of this monument continuing on in the same vein
as Vespasian and Titus honoring this victory,
uh,
that gave legitimacy to,
the Flavian Dynasty,
but also always acknowledging and thinking of the impact that it's going to have
on the Senate and the people of Rome,
the Central Bay.
If you stand right below it,
uh,
and look up,
you will see the bolt of the interior of the arch.
Uh,
and you can see that it has a coffered ceiling as we've seen so often in Roman
monuments,
quite well preserved with the coppers and then the Rosettes,
uh,
in the center.
And if I show you a,
another detail of that,
you'll get an even better sense of it.
And also of how,
or Nate,
the decoration is,
we've talked about the fact that the Flavian has had a particular interest in
very ornate decoration.
And you can see that as well here.
In fact,
the drill has been so used so extensively that it almost d materializes.
The bolt,
I think in a very interesting way of creating a kind of overall tapestry of dark
and light.
And then in the center,
a panel that is surrounded by a Garland,
uh,
and in the center of that panel,
a depiction,
you can probably barely see it from where you sit,
but a depiction of Titus being carried to heaven on the back of an eagle.
In this case,
Titus is not in military dress,
but in a toga.
He's on the back of an eagle with outstretched wings and that Eagle is taking
him up to the heavens.
What this is is a representation of apotheosis,
a p,
s apotheosis or divinization,
the divinization because the Romans believed that they could make humans into
God's after their death,
the making of Titus into a god after his death and the depiction of the material
depiction of him actually being carried to heaven on the back of an eagle,
a very powerful image.
And the fact that it is in the arc of volt,
uh,
of this,
of this ball tier has led scholars to suggest that it is possible that the arch
of Titus in Rome served as Tituss tomb and that seems to be corroborated by the
fact that behind the attic or inside the attic of the arch is a staircase as
well as a chamber.
And I show both of them to hear a spiral staircase and a chamber,
a chamber that might well have served as a burial chamber for an earn a of
Titus.
The urn was never fat,
was not found in the excavation of this monument.
So we can't prove this,
but I think it's very possible that this arch served as a tomb for the emperor
Titus.
Titus Titus was succeeded as I've already mentioned by his younger brother
Domitian,
uh,
whom you see in two portraits here,
portrait from Munich on the left and military garb and then a bust length
portrait in Rome on the right hand side of the screen.
Demission was born in [inaudible] 51 so he was only your age,
about 19 when Titus went off to the Jewish wars.
Uh,
there was never any question that the mission would succeed as brother Vespasian
was in this for the long haul.
He created a dynasty and expected both of his sons,
verse Titus,
his older son,
and then his younger son Demission to succeed him.
So dimensions eventual rise to power was never in question.
Uh,
and yet demission was jealous of his brother who was very popular in Rome,
as I've already mentioned,
and who had this great military victory on which the Flavian based their claim
to rule and demission was,
was very jealous of his brother.
He felt out of the loop.
And so when he succeeded,
uh,
Titus quicker than he thought because Titus died way before his time.
And his thirties is,
you know,
when demission succeeded Titus,
he came to power as a very embittered man and he never got over that bitterness.
And in fact,
what we see demission doing is really reverting to the mega Lamont maniacal way
of thinking of people like Caligula and Nero exercising his imperial
prerogatives to the fullest.
And,
uh,
in fact even insisting that he be a,
he,
that he be dressed as Lord and God Domino's at Davis,
which I've put on your monument list for you.
Don't miss a day,
is it Lord and God.
Uh,
and he not surprisingly given his bent,
he not surprisingly moved away from the public architecture that Vespasian and
Titus had favorite for best basion of course buildings like the coliseum for
Titus,
the bads of Titus,
uh,
the public architecture that had been favored by his father and his brother.
He moved back to being interested in building palatial architecture,
essentially,
uh,
to his own glory.
And we're going to see that the major monument that he commissioned was the
imperial palace on the Palatine Hill that had been begun by co,
by Tiberius and Caligula.
He completed that palace in the 90s,
a d before we get to that,
which will be our main focus today I would like,
cause it's extensive and there's a lot to see.
I would like to,
um,
say a few words about another commission of demission because he wasn't without
the desire to at least build some public buildings.
And I'd like to begin with one of those here.
This is a model of the so called stadium of Demission Nice Stadium or race
course,
uh,
that was used,
that was put up during the missions rain.
We date it usually to the latter part of his reign,
92 to 96 a d.
And you see that model again here and you can tell a lot about this building,
uh,
from both the scanty remains,
but also from other,
other evidence that allows us to be able to reconstruct it relatively
accurately.
Uh,
you see it here.
These stadia at were hairpin and shape.
As you can see a straight end on one side,
a curved end on the other,
but long elongated,
a kind of elongated oval with one,
a straight side.
As you can see,
it was put up in very similar fashion to theaters and to amphitheaters in that
they built a concrete a hill and line that concrete hill with stone seats and
then buttressed it with a wall.
As you can see here,
uh,
that was decorated just like the theater of Marcellus or like the coliseum
within this case,
two tiers of arches to two sets of arcades,
uh,
with columns in between them.
Those columns,
again,
having no structural purpose whatsoever,
just used as decoration for the monument.
And then the exits and entrances again,
done very similarly to amphitheater or theater architecture as we've discussed
it thus far.
So the main difference is it's not quite as tall as amphitheaters for example,
or theaters.
And just two tiers of columns as you can see here.
Uh,
and the main dish,
the main difference in plan is that it's a hairpin shape again,
with one straight side and one curved side,
only a small one can see today.
And this is essentially underground and what survives of it is underground,
although there's one section that can still be seen as I'll show you in a
moment.
But what's absolutely miraculous is the,
is the fact that the actual hairpin shape of the stadium of demission is
preserved in its entirety in the shape of one of Rome's most famous Piazza's.
And my favorite by far the Piazza Navona,
which you see from the air here in a Google earth image.
And you can see again the exact shape,
the straight side,
uh,
and the curved side of demission stadiums still preserved in the Piazza Navona
in Rome.
Uh,
it's,
it's a wonderful Piatsa for those of you who've been there.
I'm sure you,
you,
you have enjoyed spending time there.
For those of you who haven't,
it really is a mecca,
uh,
within Rome.
And you can see not only,
not only is it a pleasant place to walk,
uh,
but also a place to see great buildings.
For example,
Francesco Borromini knees on [inaudible] Goanna and Bernini's,
a four rivers famous four rivers fountain in the center of the Piazza in
dialogue with one another.
And as we look at this from the air and we look at the,
at the curved and of the Piazza Navona,
you can see this one street that you can take out of that curved end when small
street.
If you take a left,
uh,
and then a left again,
you will see the remains of the stadium of demission.
I'm going to show those to you in a moment.
And if you stay in the center of the Piatsa near the four rivers found,
and then you go,
uh,
I sort of diagonally across from that,
you will end up at one of the four best ice cream places in Rome.
It gets,
cause you can get some of the best gelato in Roman.
You get good gelato almost anywhere in Rome and in Italy.
But the very best,
uh,
this is one of those four,
say something more about that in a moment.
Here are the remains of the,
uh,
of the stadium of demission that can still be seen.
Very few tourists a notice this,
but it's well worth looking at cause you can see the brick face,
cement construction that served for the,
that was how the substructures of this building were built.
And I think you can even see that from a distance here,
uh,
made out of concrete faced with brick,
but the arcades and the columns that I showed you before out of travertine
Ashler Masonry,
travertine,
which was one of the last buildings actually in Rome to be made of travertine
Ashleigh Masonry.
Uh,
just to,
to show you also that again,
just as we,
when we were in Coppery,
I showed you the bar to Berio and it's referenced in Tiberius.
It's amazing what those who put up restaurants and bars and so on,
uh,
around Rome.
It's,
it's amazing.
It demonstrates the,
the strong sense of history that Italians have because I just,
the fact that they recognize that these are remains from the stadium of
demission.
Everyone thinks of this structure as the Piazza Navona,
but the fact that they are well aware of the fact that it was demission stadium
so that the wine bar across the street,
and this is one that was just opened the last couple of years,
the wine bar across the street,
uh,
is called the domain Siano that don't meet Siano after demission because it's
right across the street from the stadium of demission with regard to ice cream.
I take my gelato seriously and I'm sure all of you have been to Italy feel the
same way.
It's like,
it's not like American ice cream,
not that American ice cream isn't good.
Uh,
but it's,
it's absolutely fantastic.
And I,
so I will make some recommendations,
uh,
this semester and this is the first one that I'm going to make,
cause it's one of my favorites and everyone agrees this is one of the best ice
cream parlors and Rome.
It's called trace Galena.
It's also a restaurant,
a restaurant you can pass on so many restaurants in the center of famous
Piazza's.
It's not the best,
but uh,
yeah,
and you don't have to sit outside,
although they will try to beckon you to sit outside because it costs more to eat
the ice cream outside than it does.
If you just walk into,
we'll walk through the door.
There are actually two doors,
one on that's I want on this dot.
Go right up to the counter.
Take a look at what's there and make your order.
And I,
the,
my recommendation for this particular geolog Therea,
uh,
is the Tartu fee.
They are very famous.
These,
this is the best Tartufo in Rome without question.
If you like chocolate,
uh,
it's,
it's a chocolate bomb essentially,
as you can see in these images here it is one big,
well,
fairly large,
uh,
very rich,
chocolate with big,
big,
the biggest chocolate chips you ever saw on it.
And then they,
they put a doll up,
I don't even whipped cream,
but when it's pawn,
not when it's pawn on top of the Tartufo,
I go the whole way.
So you have the pond on top of the Tartufo phone.
If you sit outside and a willing to pay extra,
they'll throw a pure,
a wet on the top.
If not,
you have to forego the farewell.
But I really highly recommend what do you like chocolate or you don't like
chocolate?
I've gone with people who are not the kind of junk all the guy,
um,
uh,
who,
who um,
who like this anyway,
so it's really a treat and at least once when you're in Rome,
you have to indulge in a Tartufo at Tracy Delaney.
I want to move from dimensions,
a stadium to the building that we're going to concentrate on today because
again,
it is so extensive and that is dimensions palace on the Palatine Hill will
usually refer to it as the emissions palace on the Palatine Hill or the imperial
palace on the Palatine Hill.
Uh,
but the nomenclature is,
is,
is complex because it,
in antiquity it was referred to as the Domus,
the dome.
Most owl goose Donna,
like the Dome is our,
yeah,
Golden House of Neuro.
The Dome was,
was Donna Augustus,
his house,
essentially,
because by this point,
uh,
the word Augustus had become synonymous with emperor.
So every emperor was the Augustus.
Uh,
so this is the Domus Augustana,
uh,
which again,
continuous construction.
We talked about the fact that Tiberius had begun a palace on the Palatine hill
on the slope of the Palatine Hill that Caligula had added to that his
successors,
Claudius,
uh,
was not that interested in palatial architecture is you'll remember a neuro had
other plans for the Dome is transitory and for the dome salary.
So it was left to the Flavian specifically to demission to complete the imperial
palace,
which he does.
Uh,
and then it is dedicated as you can see from the monument list in [inaudible]
92.
We also know the architect of the dome.
Miss,
uh,
I was Donna and that was a man by the name of rebellious r a.
B.
I,
r.
U s very important Roman architect by the name of rebellious,
to get back to the nomenclature for a moment.
So the actual name of the palace was the Domus Augustana.
But here's where it gets complicated.
There's also a public wing of the house and a private wing of the house,
the public wing,
and you can see it in this Google earth image from the air.
The public wing is on one story and we see that over here.
And that was referred to an ancient times as the Flavian House,
the Domus Labia,
the Domus,
Flavio,
the private wing was on two stories or part of it was on two stories.
You can see it here,
it's even larger,
more extensive.
Uh,
and that was called in ancient times also the domeless [inaudible].
So the way this word,
the domus out who's done a referred both to the private way as opposed to the
dome is Flavia,
but also to the palace as a whole.
So I just wanted you to be aware of that because as you do your reading in the
textbooks and so on,
you might find that a little bit confusing.
But we can make,
we can simplify it completely and just call it the palace of division on the
Palatine Hell,
which is what I suggest we do.
So once again,
we can see quite good in this view from the air,
the way in which this,
uh,
this,
[inaudible] structure was planned and built a,
we see over here for example,
and I'm going to show you these implant plan and also the remains shortly.
Uh,
we can see on the upper left,
uh,
what is a basilica next to that,
an audience hall,
a Great Fountain Court over here and try Clinique IOM or dining room,
uh,
over here.
And then fountains on either side that belonged to the Domus Flavio or the
public room,
uh,
public,
area of the palace public section of the palace.
And then over here,
the private area,
as I said,
larger on two stories right here with a court in the center and a whole host of
small rooms surrounding that living quarters and so on for demission and others,
a peristyle court,
another Paris,
Dell court,
and then a great something stadium.
Uh,
over here on the right,
this was a far cry from Romulus is huts as you see them.
The Romulus is village of the eighth century BC that I remind you of over here
and show you what has happened in the Inter Inter,
uh,
in the interlude.
But what's extremely important,
I think given a dimensions view of themself as Lord and God is dominus Deus.
Uh,
it's interesting to see what he builds.
And he certainly felt that he was very much in the tradition of Romulus.
He wants to associate himself with Romulus and also of course with Augustus,
who lived,
as,
you know,
on the Palatine Hill.
But at the same time,
he wants to inject a,
his living space with the kind of brand juror that had not been,
that was certainly true under Nero and his domain salary,
but they did not been true for any of the other earlier Roman emperor.
So the don't miss our,
the impact of the Domus area once again,
is something we should think about as we look at this incredible palace.
This is a,
uh,
a plan from the Ward Perkins Textbook that perhaps shows you better than the
view from the air exactly what this,
this structure was all about.
We see the,
uh,
the,
public wing on the lefthand side,
the Domus Flavia of the palace on the Palatine Hill.
And it includes,
as you can see in the upper left corner,
a basilica basilica,
a room with a central central space divided by two side aisles by columns.
Uh,
and that was a basilica that,
that demission himself sat in and tried cases in as the judge.
Then next to that and audience hall or an hour law,
a l a,
uh,
that was the place where demission met with visiting dignitaries.
Uh,
then on access with the,
Oh,
I'll up in the upper right,
a lararium,
which was a place where they kept the household gods and so on.
Then on access with the audience,
all the Paris style,
the peristyle.
And if you,
and if you look at that and plan,
it's got columns,
of course it's Paris,
dials do,
but look at what's in the center of it.
It actually is a fountain and it is the fountain that is octagonal in shape.
So the impact of Nero's Domus aurea immediately clear the impact of that
remarkable octagonal room on the architecture of the mission and on the
architect rib area.
So a,
an octagonal fountain.
And then on access with the Allah or audience hall,
the peristyle is the try Klinean or dining room of the house of very large
dining room with panoramic windows through which one could see a very
interestingly elliptically shaped fountain one on either side.
Now as you look at that plan of the Domus Labia,
and especially at the basilica,
the audience hall and the Tri Klinean,
there was one feature that all three of those have in common that I haven't yet
mentioned.
Uh,
which is what,
okay,
all three of them have what?
No,
one
half circle.
Okay.
And I exactly.
And apps and apps on one end and all of those apps is facing the same direction.
The basilica is an Apps,
the audience,
all as an apps if try Klinean has an APP,
those were dimensions apses.
That's where demission sat domain as a day as he wanted to be honored,
in fact worshipped as Lord and God,
and he needed a space to do it in and he wanted to sit on a throne underneath
the Dome of Heaven in a sense of the Dome of Heaven was a bolt made out of
concrete and decorated in some way in antiquity,
probably with mosaic or whatever,
to give it the sense of a dome of Heaven.
He wanted to sit in that space in every one of those rooms.
So whether he was trying a la carte court case,
just welcoming visiting dignitaries or eating in his try Klinean he wanted to
sit,
uh,
beneath at least a semi dome of Heaven.
And that's indeed what he did as he was again,
worshiped as dominus a day or so.
This,
this is a very important,
I think,
a phenomenon in this particular monument and one that is well worth thinking
about,
uh,
in terms of the way in which architecture is used by a given individual's to
define themselves,
to define their lives and to define their era.
Over here.
Again,
the private wing.
I'm going to hold on that for a moment.
We'll come back to that shortly.
This is a deep,
a detail of the basilica where see the plan of the basilica and also a cross
section of the same structure.
And you can see it is,
it is completely in keeping with other basilican architecture.
We've looked at both in civic,
uh,
locations and elsewhere.
A central nave within apps on one end.
Again,
imagine demission sitting over here,
uh,
the central nave divided from the side aisles by columns.
A fairly simple but a very interesting structure in the context of this
particular palace over here and outstanding restored view that probably gives
you a better sense in almost anything I can show you of the dome is Flavio or
the public space of demolitions palace.
Uh,
here's of course the basilica over here and you can see that this room,
like all of the rooms in this palace,
uh,
were done in marble and that marble was a various colors as you can see here.
And it was marble that was brought from all over the world.
We talked about the fact that the Flavian did this,
we talked about this as the case for the temple and pockets.
For example,
bringing marble from Egypt and Asia minor and Greece,
uh,
and uh,
elsewhere in the Roman world.
Bringing it all here and using it,
using that very gated marble to make,
to get to ornament.
Obviously this palace in Rome over here,
the outlaw or the,
the upgrade audience hall,
the [inaudible],
we call it over here also with the marble on the floor as well as on the walls.
You can see that this particular room and it was apparent and plan as well,
has a scalloping on either around the edge,
around the perimeter of the room,
a series of niches,
as you can see with,
with the statuary in them,
surrounded by columns to tears with other windows up above.
As you can see and hear you get a sense of that,
uh,
of that space in which demission would've sat the apps of the room,
the curvature of the wall made of course,
that of concrete as this entire structure was made out of concrete with a semi
dome.
And you have to again,
imagine a demission sitting beneath that are inside that apps and beneath that
semi dome here,
the peristyle court open to the sky,
uh,
columns all around,
covered colonnade,
two stories,
uh,
and then in the center,
this octagonal fountain,
leave it to Demission,
leave it to rebury as to transform Nero's octagonal room into a fountain in the
context of this palace.
And then on access again with the Aloe Rajah and with the Paris style is the Tri
Clint Iom.
And this restored view again gives you a very good sense of that apps in which
demission would have sat in throne with the semi dome above his head.
Uh,
two tiers.
Again,
the walls decorated with very gated marbles brought from all different parts of
the world as well as with columns and then picture windows through which would
see these very interesting elliptical fountains as you dined one on either side
of the structure,
there's a lot of controversy as to how the,
the rooms that were roofed were roofed,
whether they had barrel vaults or not.
Or you can see this particular restored view shows one flat roof.
And when barrel vaulted a roof,
we're not absolutely sure about that.
And again,
scholars continue to argue,
which was the case here.
I mentioned statuary in the [inaudible] and we have some evidence for what that
statuary might have been like and the way in which it was used by demission.
I show you two examples.
These are two statues,
one representing Hercules on the left and the other on the right representing a
Paulo.
And you can,
and these are truly colossal in scale.
Uh,
and uh,
they are made a beautiful materials.
Again,
imported materials in this case,
a kind of a Maroon colored stone in this case,
a green greenish colored stone.
Again,
they're very large in scale,
colossal in scale and you can see the exaggerated musculature of both of these
figures.
And I think they are very telling in terms of,
you know,
as we,
as we think about demission sitting in rooms like the aloe,
Reggie,
greeting visitors.
And when you think about what this man who wanted to be worshiped as Lord and
God thought of himself and you see the kind of statuary that he surrounded
himself with,
this is a very different man than his predecessor,
Claudius,
uh,
the kind of imagery that he associated himself with.
Its as a way of pumping himself up I think by having himself surrounded by these
very athletic figures of Hercules and also of Apollo.
Uh,
what do you think this is just from looking at it?
The remains,
you can see the remains are not as extensive as one which is they were,
but enough is there to allow a reconstruction of the hall.
What are we looking at here?
The,
the Octagonal Fountain,
the Octagonal Fountain of the peristyle court.
Excellent.
It's really the most,
most people who wander around these remains were not be able to figure out for
the life of themselves what this was.
But you'll be glad when you go up on the Palatine Hill to,
uh,
to know as you stand here that this was once an octagonal fountain with this
spectacular water display.
Undoubtedly
this is the try Clint IOM or what survives sad,
what survives of dimensions.
Try Klinean.
This is his apps.
This is the very abs in which,
uh,
demission would've sat and throned as he ate with special invited guests as he
held a state dinner in Rome.
Uh,
and you can see if you look very carefully,
again,
the construction is brick faced concrete construction.
We talked about the fact that after the fire of 64,
a decision was made to begin to,
uh,
to,
use brick as a facing because brick was more fireproof than stone.
Uh,
and we see that borne out,
the entire imperial palace on the Palatine Hill was made a brick based concrete
construction.
But if you look very carefully,
you will see some stucco and you will also see some marble revetments.
So in this case,
that brick was covered over with marble to give it a much more luxurious look
for the Domina sit day is also interesting here.
Actually.
There's a tea,
there's a tarp on top of preserve mosaic and I'll show you that mosaic in a
moment.
But what's interesting here is the uh,
the,
the pavement rests on something that should remind you of something we saw
earlier in this semester,
which is what,
when do you're nodding.
So the hypo cost,
it's a hypercar system.
Justice we saw in the snobby and bass in Pompei,
they have raised the pavement up on these piles of brick and then in between
them would have place terracotta pipes and also a braziers with hot hot hot
coals and so on and so forth to heat the floor of the Tri Klinean so that
demission could not only sit in his abs but could have his feet warm while he
ate.
This gives you again,
I think a really good window into the kind of man we are dealing with here and
what he was trying to achieve.
Once again,
through architecture,
through architecture.
This is another view of the apps in which demission sat.
And here we do see,
you know,
without the tarp we can see that the mosaic is actually pretty well preserved.
And it is the colors that we so often find in Roman mosaics,
especially in major public buildings and in private policies of this combination
of green,
Maroon,
and white,
as you see here with a variety of very attractive geometric shapes.
Again,
you can see the concrete construction faced with brick and you can see the
remains of some of the marble revetment that would have covered the walls and
made this all that much more ostentatious in ancient Roman times.
This fountain is a Marvel,
I love this fountain.
This is the fountain that you see.
You're one of the two that you would see through the panoramic windows of the
power of the,
uh,
try cladium and dimensions palace.
And this is where I think the gene,
the genius of rubbish rebellious shows through and rebury his shows in a sense
himself to be the frank Gehry of his day.
I mean somebody who really enjoyed undulating,
undulating forms and the way in which concavity and convexity can be played off
against one another to great result.
Uh,
it's an elliptical founded.
It's fairly small in scale,
it's elliptical as you can see here.
Uh,
and the,
uh,
the convexity of that ellipse played off and you see it repeated again here,
played off against these interesting undulating walls.
All of this created again out of concrete and faced with bricks.
So you imagine the bricks have to be very carefully,
uh,
molded to fit where they need to fit in to this incredible scheme.
And of course in antiquity,
this would have been stuccoed over and probably had some marble revetment on it
and so on and so forth.
Uh,
but the shape is absolutely marvelous and I think we are definitely in the
presence of a great architectural genius in the person of Liberia who was
working for,
uh,
for demission,
the private wing of the palace.
Equally spectacular in its own way.
I mentioned to you already that it's more,
it's larger and in,
uh,
in the space that it covers.
Then the Domus Flavio and part of it is on two stories.
The part that you see over here,
there's a fountain court in the center.
Uh,
and then two stories of rooms around that.
Another peristyle back here.
And then a stadium once again,
a hairpin shape with a curved side and the flat side,
just like his stadium in Rome.
But he already had a stadium where he could public stadium where one could watch
race horses and these races and the like.
He used this instead and it's actually sunken cause remember this part is two
stories.
This is sunken eyes,
Sunken Stadium next to it.
It was used as a place for a pleasurable walks as a kind of outdoor garden aware
demission and again,
a special visitors,
uh,
could,
could spend some,
some time,
a pleasant place to walk within the city.
Uh,
we see here,
uh,
another of the accident metric view from Ward Perkins where we can also get a
very good sense,
not only of the Domus Flavio as we've already described it.
Uh,
the basilica and the owl on one end,
the octagonal fountain in the center.
And then over here,
the dining hall with the two,
uh,
to,
elliptical fountains.
One on either side.
Here we see again the private area with the sunken stadium over here with the
Peristyle Court,
with a fountain in the center.
Two stories around that.
Uh,
and then over here,
another couple of other peristyle courts are actually three peristyle courts in
total here.
But what's interesting,
I think when you look at this accident,
a metric view,
I think it's interesting to see that kind of cutaway view,
uh,
that to see that from the outside,
a lot of these spaces didn't look as interesting as they did from the inside.
We are definitely moving,
I mean we've seen that be the case for a while,
but he's,
it'd be Roman architecture.
Think back to some of the early residents is in palm pay where they were very
plain and severe on the outside.
But when you went in inside and saw the atrium and the medium and the comm
plutonium in the,
and the garden,
it was something else.
Again,
this whole element of surprise.
And that's true even here I think in this palace where the structures are less
interesting from the outside and more interesting from the interiors of them.
Here's the Google Earth image again of just the private part of the palace where
we see this interesting Paris dial court,
the other two peristyle courts behind it.
Uh,
these rooms placed on two stories and then once again,
Sunken Stadium,
Sunken Stadium is actually quite well preserved.
As you can see here,
it's one of the better preserved parts of the villa today.
You can get a very good sense,
not only of a shape and also its scale,
its enormous,
huge stadium.
Uh,
and again you'll have to imagine demission wandering around here.
and uh,
you can see the curved end on one side,
but most importantly the concrete construction faced with brick and including
columns and other marble.
That meant this is a view of that first court,
the one that has rooms on two stories around it.
Once again,
rebellious has had a great deal of fun with his fountain.
He seems to have taken particular pleasure and designing fountains and in
letting his magic imagination run free.
With regard to fountain design,
uh,
you see,
you see here,
uh,
again he's playing off,
convex against concave.
He's done all of this out of uh,
out of concrete.
They shapes are done in concrete,
faced with brick and again,
the bricks have to be molded,
very special lead to fit the space within that,
that they need to accommodate themselves to.
And if any of you know anything about those female warriors called the Amazons,
they carry shields called as p e l t a as they should remind you,
don't they look Robert like pell tie?
Uh,
they look very much like,
I don't know,
that's probably coincidental.
I'm not implying here that there's any,
um,
any particular iconography to this particular fountain,
but who knows.
But they do look very much like shields that are carried by Amazonian women.
But at any rate,
this playing off of convex against concave Burberry's is clearly enjoying
himself with this monument.
Then the rooms on two stories and you see,
just as we saw quite quite some time ago in the second phase of the villa,
the mysteries where they were beginning to open up the exterior and create bay
windows and more windows and make it less severe than it had been in the
original.
Don't Miss Vitalik like we see that sort of thing here.
Many more windows you the wall being opened up,
they've gotten so sophisticated in their use of concrete,
uh,
that they are able to,
um,
to open the,
the walls up more with these rectangular windows of different shapes.
As you can see,
some large,
some smaller,
some on the ground,
some higher sort of like windows and then above,
uh,
additional,
um,
openings that are,
that are RQ waited on the top.
So clearly he's again,
having,
enjoying,
uh,
opening up this wall and creating interesting,
interesting,
uh,
views from one part of the structure to another.
Two more,
two more images of that wonderful fountain where I think you can see even better
the way in which this has all been done out of concrete,
faced with brick.
And you have to imagine,
of course,
the spectacular water display.
The found the actual water jets that would've come up,
uh,
the Bellagio,
it may not have been,
but it probably was something,
you know,
sort of pride,
the ancient version of the Bellagio in Las Vegas.
Uh,
the fountains at the Bellagio here you see a restored view of this fountain
court where you get a sense that once you add a bunch of statuary,
some water jets,
which you don't see actually working here,
uh,
and paint the walls,
the whole thing would have been even more spectacular still.
And I think that gives you some general sense of the original appearance of the
palace around the,
uh,
the,
um,
the court,
the Fountain Court and the private wing that we've just looked at.
There were a series of rooms and if you look at some of those rooms in detail,
I think you'll be amazed by what you see.
Some fantastically shape rooms,
some of them cruciform cross shaped,
uh,
some of them going way back to the frigging Daria with,
you know,
circular rooms with radiating alcoves.
And not surprisingly,
again,
given,
uh,
what,
Severus and Keller were able to achieve at Nero's Domus Aria,
given the fact that the octagon is all clearly also in the mind of rebellious in
this building,
we see him creating small act acti octagonal rooms and exploring and
experimenting with those octagonal rooms.
And you see a couple of them and plan on the side.
And one of the sides of this Fountain Court,
I show you here a view from or several views from the Ward Perkins Textbook
where we see a cross section,
a plan,
and also an accident metric view of one of these octagonal rooms that we believe
was designed by rubbing areas for the Palatine Palace.
And I compare it down here,
uh,
to the octagonal room of Nero's domes,
Aria,
which was clearly the model for rebellious Prius's foray into,
uh,
to,
to designing opta gods.
It's a much smaller room than Nero's octagonal room,
but he takes the whole concept a step further.
It's an octagon.
Yes,
it's eight sided,
just like the dome is Aria.
Uh,
it has radiating alcoves.
some of them are rectangular,
some of them are,
are,
are circular,
as you can see here.
Uh,
and if you look at the accident metric view,
you will see two interesting things that are a step forward.
Uh,
one of them is the fact that although in the Dome is our area,
uh,
the eight sided row,
although the room was eight sided,
they,
the Dome was itself essentially,
uh,
a,
you know,
cur curved as traditional dome.
What we see happening here though is they take the eight sides and continue that
segmented feel into the dome.
So we have an eight sided segmented dome in the,
this octagonal room in the Palatine Palace,
which is different than the dome is salary.
And the other thing,
and perhaps even more significant,
is the fact that if we look at the individual niches,
we will see that they are envelopes of space.
And the same way that narrows don't Miss Al Rhea was and that they have.
And,
and just like Nero's domes,
they have just like new,
don't miss salary.
They have niches within niches.
But what [inaudible] has done here is something really quite extraordinary.
And very different from anything we've seen earlier.
Enrollment,
architecture,
and that is he's placed some of these additional niches or windows or doorways
off axis with the niche itself.
Now we have seen that the Romans cared above all about the holiday and symmetry.
And yet we see here,
and this is why I call him the Frank Gehry of the Roman are,
you know,
Roman architects.
He is willing to try something entirely different.
He is clearly unarmored of,
of circles and rectangles and domes and the like.
But he is also willing to dispense with the usual axiology of Roman architecture
and explore placing things off axis in a quite inventive way.
And I can show you that even better by looking quickly at the two views of one
of these octagonal rooms from the private wing of the Palatine Palace,
uh,
where you can see not only,
and I hope you can see it from where you are,
you can see not only the segments can you see this segmented dome,
I think quite clearly here.
Uh,
you can see these envelopes,
this space.
You can see these openings,
this whole idea of creating vistas from one,
uh,
one building to another.
Uh,
but,
and you can see the way in which these very,
that some are doorways,
some are windows,
but I think you can also see the way in which he is beginning to place.
Here's a window that is placed completely off axis with the niche.
This is even more apparent in this other view where you can see one of these
radiating niches.
And in that radiating niche,
there's an opening that starts with the floor.
And then there's another opening to the left of it that's higher up.
Uh,
and again,
you get the sense of asymmetry rather than symmetry in this.
And this is again,
very,
very experimental,
very different.
It really is different than almost anything I can show you not only before,
but even after this great work of architecture.
And it gives us some insight into the creativity of rebellious and the way in
which,
uh,
demission was allowing him to be.
Because I think this goes above and beyond.
Clearly.
Demission is imaging himself.
I think especially in the public realm of this building,
he's very concerned with how he's presenting himself to his public.
Over here.
I have the sense that he has really let rebellious be rebellious and he's let
rebellious do what he wanted to do to create an interesting architectural,
the exciting space,
uh,
in which he could live a and could enjoy some of what some of the interesting
architectural motifs that rebellious instills in this extraordinary structure.
Now to mission to mission was succeeded by John Kerry.
No,
uh,
well,
sort of in the sense that he was succeeded by a man by the name of Nerva who it
looks very much like John Kerry.
Don't you think I'm,
that's a coin of neuroma on the lefthand side of the screen.
Uh,
demission by the way,
I think I may have forgotten to mention,
but he,
he,
he ended up just the way neuro dead.
He was,
well,
in his case,
he was actually assassinated.
Nero was forced to commit suicide,
but a demission was assassinated.
He was issued a dumb not to your memorial at his death.
Uh,
and he was succeeded by Nirvana.
Nirvana,
who was appointed by the Senate.
The Senate had had it with dead spots and they decided the time had come to
choose one of their own and they selected nerva who was an elderly and very
highly respected member of the Senate.
And this was the first time the Senate did this and that,
but since the dust is founded,
the empire and,
uh,
his reign,
the first emperor of Rome,
this is the first time that an emperor was appointed by the Senate.
Uh,
nerva was a highly respected and,
and,
and pretty level headed guy and he was able to bring peace and prosperity back
to the empire.
He did not last very long,
however,
he had a very brief reign,
uh,
and uh,
and therefore very little time to have an impact on architecture.
But again,
you see him,
uh,
represented on a coin on the lefthand side of the screen.
I'd like to show you one building though I'd like to end today with one building
that was actually begun by demission and then completed by Nerva.
It began as a so called forum trends Victorian,
uh,
under demission and became the forum of Nerva under nerva.
In order to do this,
I need to take you to the general plan of the imperial for in Rome.
We've looked at this before.
You'll remember the location of the Roman Forum here and obviously down below
the form of Julius Caesar that we've already studied the forum of Augustus built
right next to that,
that we've also looked at in detail.
And then the forum pacas or the temple and pockets of Vespasian,
uh,
which we have looked at more recently and which you'll recall was built in such
a way so that it faced the forum of Augustus and the Forum of Julius Caesar next
door.
I mentioned to you,
I think already that there was a very large piece of property over here.
Uh,
that was,
uh,
that on which stood essentially one of Rome,
seven hills,
the queer and all hell.
Can You I R I n a l the clearer knowl hill of Rome occupied this area,
but it was an area that was being eyed by demission.
You can see from his palace that he had big plans and,
uh,
once the palace was coming to fruition,
he was thinking again about public architecture and the fact that he would
really like to build a forum to rival that of his father for him that was bigger
than that of his father's.
And he'd liked to put it over here facing his father's Borum across the forum of
Augustus and the Forum of Julius Caesar.
He drank,
he dreamed those big dreams,
but he was never able to realize them.
Uh,
what he did instead was to take it this area that was located between the forum
of Vespasian and the form of Augustus form of Julius Caesar.
This area that I mentioned to you was called the [inaudible].
I think I've got it there.
The are delayed them.
Uh,
that area was a street that connected the Roman forum with an area of Rome
called the Sabura Suv.
Ura.
This Bora,
which was a residential area that I mentioned was it was,
uh,
had in it mostly these wooden apartment houses,
large numbers of people lived in the suburbs.
So there was the street,
the argillite item that,
uh,
that,
attached the two or the connected the two to one another.
And demission decided to use that as a forum to himself,
uh,
that would be placed next to that if his father,
Andy placed in that forum,
a temple of his patron goddess Minerva is patron goddess was Minerva.
And he,
he,
he built a temple to honor her in this location because this forum was so,
it was like a street and was so narrow,
uh,
that had,
that had an effect on what could be built there.
So that you can see,
for example,
in plan that while the forums of Julius Caesar,
an Augustus and the foreign pockets all had colonnades covered colonnades.
In fact,
there was no space to build a covered colonnade here.
So what they had to do was place the columns very close to the wall,
uh,
and not put any ceiling on top of those columns.
You can see the same here.
This is a plan of the,
uh,
of the original forum of demission or what was called the forum transitory IOM
because it served as a point of transit between the [inaudible] and the Roman
forum.
The temple of Minerva over here consistent with temple architecture as we've
seen it thus far this semester.
Uh,
a temple with a frontal orientation,
single staircase,
a facade orientation,
freestanding columns in the porch and so on.
Uh,
the entrance way over here,
the forum pockets would be here form of Caesar and Augustus at the top.
And then you can see these bases for the columns very close to the wall and not
attached to it,
but very close to the wall on either side because there's no space for
colonnades.
He is a Google earth image showing the imperial for as it looks today,
part of the later forum of Trajan,
the forum of Augustus and what is preserved of the so called forum transitory
him over here.
This is a model of what the forum transitory and would have looked like in
ancient Roman times and the time of demission with the temple of Minerva,
uh,
with these columns and either side.
And you can see from this model the difference that that makes when you don't
have enough space to build covered colonnades.
You've got columns that look like they are projecting out of the wall with
projecting and tablature is on top of them.
We have not seen this before in built architecture.
This is a very important development.
We have seen it in painting,
but we haven't seen it in built architecture.
Here's a detail of the forum,
transitory them with these columns.
A placed almost flush with the wall of though not quite the project,
a little bit in front of the wall with the projecting and tablatures the
building,
the walls made out of two full blocks.
As you can see here,
the rest with marble and a panel at the top.
And we think that would have been lots of such panels representing the Goddess
Minerva Hymns herself.
So we see that here.
We have not seen it in built architecture before,
but we have seen it in painting.
This is a detail of curriculum 16 in the Ville of the mysteries.
And you can see one such set of columns that project out of the wall with the
projecting and tablatures up of Bob.
Uh,
so it's something again that we think may have been done in a temporary wooden
architecture for example.
Uh,
but keep in mind how early that painting is.
You all know the data because you've studied it for the exam.
It's mid BC,
so it's way before even the Augustan period.
And yet we see that there and now we finally see it in built architecture and
it's going to have a real history in Roman architecture in a very different way
than concrete does.
This whole idea of decorating a wall by placing a series of columns that project
in and out along that wall,
giving it a kind of using the traditional language of architecture columns to
create a kind of undulating wall or what we're going to call later in the
semester a baroque,
a wall to details of the uh,
some of the,
one of the surviving capitals with the freeze up above a freeze that represents
scenes of women weaving.
I'm not going to get into the meaning of all of that here today,
uh,
but you can see the way in which the columns project somewhat out of the wall,
Corinthian capitals projecting and tablature,
very highly decorated,
just like all the Flavian architectural ornament.
Uh,
as you can see here,
very deeply drilled and so on and so forth.
But this whole idea of decorating a wall in this way and instilling movement in
that wall by this undulating in and out a scheme is going to again,
have a very important future enrollment architecture.
This is an interesting view because it shows us just what we've looked at.
Some of those remaining columns from the so called form transitory and which was
renamed the forum of Nero after demission is deaf and dumb,
not tio memoria.
I Nero just took it over and said,
okay,
it's my forum now and renamed it to himself,
but didn't add anything architecturally to it.
We see it here and this is one of those great views in which you can see the
difference between modern ground level and ancient ground level.
In order to see the lower part of the form is got to go right up to the edge of
the street and looked down on it.
And this also a interesting engraving by the famous artists Pyrrhonese
Pyrrhonese print of the 18th century.
I did a lot,
a lot of wonderful prince and event.
If there's any interest in this class,
by the way,
we have plenty of these at Yale.
And I know one of the teaching fellows,
if not more than one,
would be more than happy to,
to uh,
find a time to take those of you who might be interested in looking at Pyrenees
Prince of Rome,
uh,
over to the British arts centre and so on to or elsewhere to take a look at
these.
But what's interesting about this one is it shows where the ground level was at
the time that this was in grave by,
uh,
Pyrrhonese that is in the 18th century.
It was pretty much where it is here.
It was much,
much higher than it is now.
And then when they excavated it in modern times,
they got us down to ancient ground level and to the bottoms of the columns.
I want to end up with this one last image,
uh,
because we have very different Wendy a very different,
but uh,
it,
it allows us to continue on with a,
with a point that I made when we discussed the coliseum and which has already
turned up in the online forum.
And that is the use of a Roman buildings as quarries for later architects and
later patrons,
namely princes and popes and the way in which buildings like the Colosseum where
pirated,
uh,
for later architecture in the case of the forum transitory him or the form of
nerve or we know that the temple of Minerva,
that the material out of which it's made,
the reason that it does not exist at all today,
the temple of Minerva is that it was taken apart and re reused,
uh,
by Pope Paul the fifth for a fountain that he wanted to build on the [inaudible]
hill in Rome,
the socal Aqua Paolo,
which you see here.
And the Aqua Paula,
the,
uh,
the temple was torn down in 1606,
it's still stood in 1606.
It was torn down then and it was placed in,
this founder are used for the construction of this fountain that was dedicated
in 16,
12 and built by the architect,
Giovanni Fontana.
And you see it here.
Uh,
and it's not easy to determine exactly which is,
you know,
which parts are from the temple itself,
but much of the building stone that you see here,
he reused in this fountain,
comes from the Temple of Minerva in Rome.
So it shows you the way,
again,
the way in which these buildings were used as quarries,
but the way in which Roman buildings live on,
they either live on as themselves or they live on as other buildings.
And I think that's a nice,
a nice thought and a nice note on which to end today.
Thank you.